[Music]
the plastics industry plays an important
role in the European economy 18% of the
world's plastics are produced in the EU
1.5 million people work in the European
plastics industry the European plastics
industry turns over 350 billion euros a
year transforming the plastics industry
into an environmentally sustainable
business is inevitable in fact it's
already happening so let's help our
European industry to become the leader
in change and turn sustainable
innovation into a competitive advantage
for Europe we are saying today to the
plastics industry that Europe is the
place to invest and crop there's huge
potential here to find any of these
solutions lowering costs improving
competitiveness and generating thousands
of new jobs while protecting the
environment the plastic industry is
already an economic success in Europe
now we want to help it to become an
environmental success story too for
example by reusing materials which
currently go to waste we want to provide
more opportunities for our industry to
thrive and improve the value chains that
stretch across our single market will
help create better designed ma durable
and more easily recyclable products the
plastic Strategy is a great chance for
new businesses
[Music]